I've looked and looked and looked I
cannot find a single instance
where a transgender person
has been accused of assaulting someone
in a public restroom
do you know why
because they're going in there to use
the bathroom right you're out and about
you're shopping hey I need to go relieve
myself you go in there you do your
business you wash your hands and you
leave
that that's it that's it and we're
saying that that is too much that is too
much of a privilege to extend to
transgender people they're just trying
to exist
they're not out there
breaking laws they're they're not out
there doing anything wrong they're not
coming after us they're not trying to
indoctrinate us they just want to live
and here in Florida and across the
country in red States we're saying no
Your Existence is offensive to me so I
want to oppress you